procrastination is really has nothing to
do with laziness and everything to do
with resistance and a lot of times when
people procrastinate it's really truly
because they don't feel worthy of the
thing that they're trying to make happen
erica what's the biggest obstacle you've
had to overcome in your own life that's
a good one
my biggest obstacle for sure that i have
had to overcome that i'm still working
on
is my self-worth and you know my
struggle with self-worth
um
i've done a lot of work to try to
work you know to try to heal that and
and work on that and i think that
being an artist in hollywood
requires you to put yourself out there
in a way that most people won't really
have to do in their lifetime if they
weren't pursuing a big dream you know if
they weren't trying to do something
challenging
it requires a lot of you
and
you know
through you know with through rejection
and and also through depending on what
your
job is in the industry what your craft
is
it can feel so personal you know like
what you are putting out your work that
you are putting out it is like you right
it's attached to you so i think that
you know
i tend i tend to attract a lot of
clients who are like myself and i think
a lot of artists in general struggle
with self-worth more so because it's on
display
so much more often than maybe other
people
who aren't working in an industry like
hollywood would have to you know face
essentially um which i guess it's a good
thing it's a good thing that we need to
that i should say i that i need to work
on this and that i need to
um get better but it's really been my
biggest obstacle because i think that it
impacts everything i do it impacts how i
put myself out there how i ask for
things that i want if i you know
come across as
someone who believes they're worthy of
what they want or you know i talk to my
clients a lot about
how a lot of artists come across as
desperate in the please choose me please
choose me am i good enough tell me i'm
good enough
and i think a lot of us you know
struggle with that so i myself have
struggled with that as well
and i think especially shifting into my
coaching business where i have to build
a business on me where i'm the brand and
um
it's it's been a whole extra
layer of me
working through some self-worth
stuff i guess you could say but that's
definitely been my biggest obstacle
i'm wondering if
struggles with self-worth actually
propel someone to go pretty far because
when i've done like little bits of
research on a lot of people whether it's
acting music whatever i find a lot of
them have a missing parent
and i think that that causes people to
do interesting things and so i'm
wondering if that almost propels people
to to go further where someone
who doesn't it's more safe and so
okay i didn't get this well that's all
right but somebody who really is like
obsessed with it
it actually that that
self-worth sort of wound
actually makes them rise up more i hope
i'm i'm making sense now you're making
perfect i mean tony robbins talks a lot
about the idea of
if you grew up without a lot of
trauma or obstacles or issues you're
almost in a worse spot
trying to achieve big goals
um he's you know because because of
exactly what you're talking about this
like safe comfortable kind of bubble and
and a lot of people you know look at
people like oprah who had an incredibly
challenging childhood right so a lot of
the times that people who grew up with a
lot of obstacles or potentially a lot of
trauma it does propel them you know it
does um ignite a fire perhaps or or
helps them succeed i think with
self-worth particularly it could totally
go in that direction
but
i find at least with the clients that i
work with is that more often than not it
actually does hold people back from
taking bigger risks or putting
themselves out there in a bigger way and
so they do it kind of in a safe way of
yeah and i myself
struggle with this and i know that i can
catch myself when i do this you know
sometimes i'll you know
make a post for my business or something
and i'll do it to an audience that i
know already loves and accepts me and so
you know i think that
if you if you doubt yourself
and you don't feel worthy of what you
want
it usually ends up holding you back
so like if people procrastinate
procrastination is really has nothing to
do with laziness and and everything to
do with resistance and a lot of times
when people procrastinate it's really
truly because they don't feel worthy of
the thing that they're trying to make
happen
um so i do feel like you know i think it
can definitely go in the direction that
you're talking about and i think other
obstacles and trauma absolutely does
propel somebody forward but a lot of
times with self-worth it it holds us
back from you know going after the big
things that we want
right yeah i'm thinking of like marilyn
monroe and
the lack of self-worth probably took her
very far but it also could have taken
her down unfortunately yeah i mean i
guess too you know if you don't have a
strong sense of self or strong
self-worth
you're going to let a lot of people tell
you how to live your life you know tell
you
you know back to these like hollywood
boxes like like for example if you don't
have a strong self-worth maybe you do
end up
booking projects booking shows booking
um features but
none of them feel aligned like you don't
actually feel happy you feel miserable
right because you let somebody else tell
you what you should feel or what you
should go after because you didn't feel
that you were worthy of the things that
you really want
so tony raw i i guess i maybe i have
heard that from him before but so you've
heard him say that it's actually
not an impediment to have had if having
had like sort of this safe
upbringing but
or maybe it is i don't know yeah i don't
want to i don't want to butcher his
words and say it incorrectly i'm just
i'm just recalling you know my memory of
what he said
but that was that was like i have
remembered that because i
you know it's interesting like i am
someone who is incredibly determined and
ambitious
um
but i i did have somewhat of a
comfortable life and sometimes i wonder
if
that propelled me actually this is like
a totally different topic but if that
propelled me in a way where like i feel
less scared
to go after certain things or to take
some risks because i feel like
i i still have a safety net of my family
like i have a good family life you know
so i feel like i still have this safety
net so maybe it's less scary for me than
other people but
i don't know from what i remember of
what he said
um
i'm pretty sure he did say that you know
people that
that struggled more
in their childhood or in their lives um
kind of have that
one-up on
i don't know maybe being ambitious or
pursuing your goals what's the biggest
challenge you've helped one of your
clients through one of the biggest
challenges that i have helped my clients
with
and this probably doesn't sound very
sexy but
i feel like i i feel very fortunate
to
connect with people who
are struggling in their careers and are
really down about it
um and the fortunate part comes with how
i get to help them not that i'm so glad
that people are struggling that maybe it
came out wrong but um
i've been very fortunate to connect with
these people who
feel really down about their careers
because maybe it has been some time and
they're not where they want to be yet
and so sometimes people come to me where
they're depressed and they're really
feeling down and by the end of the time
we're working together they
they feel happy again they feel excited
again in their career you know
they feel hopeful
and that energy switch
is so
crucial to what comes next in terms of
their strategic moves and what
opportunities come their way like it
really does help them bring in a new
level up opportunity and so i think you
know like i've had clients who are on
the verge of quitting and i'm like one
of their last resorts you know and so i
think for me that's
one of the most
challenging things that i've helped
clients with but i think that is so
rewarding because it's so it's so
awesome to see people who've started
feeling really down and really depressed
about their career
who now like one of my new clients i
mean we're only like a month in and
she's already feeling so excited and
hopeful and
that is just so awesome i mean you know
i just feel so fortunate to be able to
help people
like i feel like one of my superpowers
is helping people believe in themselves
and and really seeing what's possible
and so i feel honored to kind of
relight that spark for people and help
them get back to
what's possible and and get back to
their dream
well it's like dating you know like when
you're in a relationship all of a sudden
now all these people are attracted to
when you weren't yeah no one would call
no nothing happened but then all of a
sudden you give off this energy of like
i don't really need it that much or
whatever and i think that that yeah the
desperation goes yeah something happens
and
whether it's dating or business or
whatever but i don't know if the same
for
some of what you've talked about i mean
a little bit you know it's it's a to for
me it's about the energy and so and it's
about getting in alignment with the
energy of the thing that you desire so
if you're feeling really down and really
low which is normal and happens all the
time
you're not likely to attract
you know exciting new opportunities
right it's like if if you're feeling
like really low
and you're right here um
and these opportunities that you want
are up here you're not in alignment with
them
and
and so when you start to feel good again
and inspired and excited it brings you
up here and now suddenly you are in
alignment with these new opportunities
and i think from like a slightly more
tangible way to explain this
is that when you are feeling really down
and really low
you are
problem oriented
right and so and i i know that i've been
this way when i went through my really
challenging year 2009 and i was really
depressed my mom would suggest
solutions to me and she would think of
ideas to help me and i would say no to
everything i would shoot down everything
i was just not in the energy of
accepting help or accepting a solution
because i was feeling so low and so when
you're feeling hopeful and excited again
suddenly it's like oh there's
opportunity everywhere i see solutions
everywhere
so
you're my you know the your belief
system and your energy is all
controlling
the opera like opportunities might have
existed around you the whole time but
you just didn't see them you know i
always talk about the example of the
fedex logo do you know the fedex logo
um so i mean i would know the colors
it's like the purple and the rng do you
know that there's like the hidden arrow
in between the e and the acts of fedex
in the white space maybe i don't no
so i say this because a lot of people
tend to know about the arrow and and so
if you don't know about the arrow go
look at the fedex logo and so it's in
the negative space the white space
between the e and the x
um and that was intentionally done
because fedex is about you know movement
and
so
there's also
a little hidden baking spoon in the
lowercase e that most people don't know
really okay and the idea is that
even if you didn't know about that arrow
and that baking spoon
they were always there
you might have looked at that logo a
hundred times and you didn't see that
because you didn't know it was there you
didn't know to look but it doesn't mean
that they didn't exist they were always
there
so it's like when you are feeling
hopeful and excited and you're feeling
good
you know to look for opportunities that
are always around you
but if you're feeling depressed and low
you're probably not even going to see
them even though they might be right in
front of you
what do you do for people that they
can't necessarily do for themselves
two things i think one is like i talked
about i think that i help people believe
in themselves and believe in what's
possible in a way they never have before
i feel very proud i feel like it is my
superpower you know to really help
people
expand their view of what is truly
possible
and the other thing that i do that
people might not be able to do for
themselves is to see their blind spots
right so
i can usually have a conversation with
them and fairly quickly
determine where their blind spots are in
terms of like what's holding them back
you know if they talk to me about their
strategy you know i can pick out
what's really holding them back in that
strategy
what the limiting belief is you know
just the other day i was on a podcast
interview and i was coaching the
the
one of the hosts and he talked about how
him and his producing partner they they
live
um somewhere else in the united states
and they're working on moving to las
vegas
and
and they had this whole plan about why
that was a good decision
and i said tell me why you're moving to
las vegas instead of la tell me why
you're not moving to la
right and so
they told me all these reasons that
we're really fear-based they didn't
believe that they could afford to live
here they didn't believe they'd find any
work they didn't you know they had all
these stories that they decided on
um that created their decision and then
that decision leads to
dream adjacent
right and so i think that um we can't
always see our blind spots that's why i
work with coaches too you know i have
people help me with my blind spots
and so we can't we can't see them on our
own you know because our mind is really
good
at justifying our decisions
our mind is really good at coming up
with reasons or excuses about why what
we're doing
is
the right thing to do or the best thing
for us
but a lot of times you know we're
holding ourselves back
and so i help people
with that and and really helping them
recognize where their blind spots may be
you